E aí
o órgão Bom dia a todos peço desculpa
mas isto mais carioca é uma coisa que
não funciona na problemas aqueles
aqueles cultivavam a vinha aqui hoje
para para para para você apresentar
nesse assim uma pequena história mas
Possivelmente a história mais desafiando
que nós temos pela frente é uma história
não convencional uma história que vai
ter no início depois tu vai ter um sim
ou não não faço a mínima ideia mas de
qualquer maneira é uma história que
sobretudo é uma história de perguntas e
com todas as histórias tem tem o início
e este início somos nós não temos local
e sobretudo com aquilo que são as nossas
exclusividades ou seja aquilo como nós
como seres humanos dominantes termos a
intersecção das possibilidades e uma das
primeiras possibilidades que nós
tínhamos na nossa história Era as
possibilidades de sermos o centro do
universo ou seja planeta terra e tudo
que habitava a volta
e chegou um senhor Copérnico e que
provamos que afinal de contas meio assim
nós temos um bocadinho. Nesta imensidão
do universo mesmo assim com se
continuamos e considerar os mesmos
outras exclusividade pela exclusividade
já que não era do universo pelo menos no
planeta Terra temos essa exclusividade
ser aqui colocados tipo uma divindade ou
seja sermos aqui qualquer coisa tipo Um
ser superior só depois surge um senhor
outras conhecem Darwin e podemos dizer
que não sabe uma questão de evolução em
termos de espécies juntos há casos de
acontecimentos
é mas nós enquanto seres humanos um
cadinho teimosos e perder exclusividades
para nós é terrível seja encaminhando
for e continuamos a considerar já que
não tenhas cuidado do universo já que
não tenha exclusividades dominante em
termos do planeta terra por mês sem
exclusividade da tomada de decisões
conscientes ou seja Essência todas as
decisões que ele toma toma de forma
consciente depois chegou mais um chato
vocês também tinha aqui Floyd e vemos
por vaca na parte das decisões que nós
tomar vamos tomar umas formas
inconsciente ou seja tentamos por isso é
uma parte das coisas que fazemos e então
ele começa tornar extremamente
aborrecido porque é pensarmos afinal de
contas qual aqui a nossa outra
exclusividade eu estou encontramos mais
uma quer exclusividade
a inteligência seja aquilo que fora
inteligência e continuamos com essas
possibilidades até chegarmos a cerca de
a gente chegou até chato para nós
podemos todas as possibilidades Alan
turing escreve um artigo fabuloso não
sei se eu tive a oportunidade de ler
senão não leram e que ele tem uma frase
e a frase que eu coloco essas máquinas
podem pensar e nem sei assim nós estamos
nestes momentos Então mas a perder esta
nossa última exclusividade as
possibilidades de inteligência onde
começamos a ter a gente só não
precisamos a ter desafios em que começam
a colocar em causa essa mesma
exclusividade e tudo se sente em termos
o nosso cérebro e com nós sabemos uma
ser um órgão Fantástico mas ao mesmo
tempo muito enigmático ou seja são
biliões neurônios sinapses acontecer
constante mento e que nós temos essa
dificuldade em perceber e ao mesmo tempo
tinha não conseguimos perceber muito bem
seja a inteligência seja a consciência
sejam todos esses mecanismos somos
colocados perante os desafios que ao
mesmo tempo São desafios muito complexo
eu fiz fantásticos e entra aqui a
questão da inteligência artificial
é o nome propriamente de vida e
inteligência artificial talvez não sejam
nome mais correto por duas razões
É porque tem a palavra inteligência e
por ter a palavra artificial ou seja
qualquer coisa que é inteligente nós Não
vimos comercial e aquilo que artificial
dificilmente será inteligente Mas
qualquer maneira 1956 não conferência a
conferência de alma de cima os pais
Inteligência Artificial forma carci
entre outros cunharam tanto esse tempo
hoje em dia discutimos justificassem
Inteligência Artificial ser a
inteligência sintética inteligência da
máquina eu gosto mais de ver isto como
inteligência aumentada ou seja na
Essência a capacidade das imitações que
nós temos em termos um outro mecanismo
podemos chamar inteligente como nós Já
percebemos que inteligência extremamente
difícil mas que tem a capacidade de
aumentar aquilo que a nossa capacidade
podes patamares porque os desafios que
estão colocação desafios ter menos hoje
em dia e nós apesar de termos por esta
capacidade tem das nossas limitações e
começamos a viver ela
a viver momentos em que começamos a
perceber que nós feitos de carbono
começamos a misturar com estes temas
feitos de silício E começamos a ter este
interligar destes dois sistemas ou
desses dois ecossistemas e começa a ser
muito difícil nós percebemos onde é que
situamos onde é que estamos tem a que
somos
o e temos uma outra limitação
E essas mutações apresentada por cano
mesmo escreveu o livro Fantástico pensar
devagar e depressa quando apresenta o
sistema um e o sistema dois e o último
ele apresentamos esta questão do ruído
ou seja nas decisões que nós temos temos
sentimentos ruído seja os nossos
julgamentos seja nessas mesmas decisões
e claramente precisamos destes temas que
consiga iluminar todo este ruído e que
consigam darmos a capacidade de
respondermos estes enormes desafios
os grupos dizia estes momentos que
vivemos e por vezes nos apercebemos por
todas as transformações temos todos os
tempos dos seus momentos e são
diferentes do ponto de vista geográfico
é que acontecem nós estamos no momento
de difícil percepção Clara é como se
fosse como se tivéssemos a viver ou como
se fosse um no Mangal licença um
ecossistema onde a água doce e água
salgada se mistura estamos apresentados
por Flora e o ecossistema muito difícil
nós conseguimos perceber é tal questão
sinal de hoje em dia somos analógicos +
ou somos digitais correto é que estão
não só o espaço Mas nos espaços entre os
passos o tarot online tarot online
Olá neste momento aumentar sem fechar os
olhos e possivelmente todos de voz tem
um smartphone estão interligados no
sistema qualquer estão fisicamente aqui
mas Possivelmente estarão digitalmente
outro lado qualquer esse chá se nos
olhos imaginássemos todos os circuitos
da digital que estão neste momento
acontecer nós temos muito esta
dificuldade em perceber estes
ecossistemas EA forma como os vimos e
isto leva-nos a estes desafios têm
Inteligência Artificial reparem que o a
pouco dizia não se sua mãe providenciar
especial mas quando atribuímos um nome é
difícil fugir esse mesmo nome e a gente
licenciado oficial Hoje é dia tá em todo
lado nós sabemos que ela sobre tudo
começou ali na década de 50 com Alan
turing depois com a tal conferência onde
foi cunhado este tempo eles esse termo
Mas o que aconteceu e tivemos de cerca
de cinquenta 60 anos sobretudo
desenvolvimentos onde houve períodos um
desenvolver muito períodos onde parou
esse desenvolvimento mas eu
o último dez anos naquilo que eu chamo o
campo da Integração bocadinho para
coca-cola primeiro estranha-se depois
entranha-se e hoje em dia temos a
inteligência artificial em todo lado
basicamente vocês sem smartphone como Já
vos disse no vosso convosco certeza que
a inteligência artificial os nossos
marketphones com esses Inteligência
Artificial temos inteligência artificial
na saúde temos na economia temos na
educação temos nos carros temos no
desporto em tudo aquilo que se possa
imaginar E estes todos estes grandes
desafios do ponto de vista o digital não
há uma linha de meta para isto vou fazer
uma forma que conseguimos fugir ou seja
são as tempo a vai até ali paro não o
derramamento é continuar nós como seres
humanos temos essa sede continuar
querido evoluir temos é que seria como é
que nós nos conseguimos adaptar mesmos
momentos nesse mesmo século sistemas
como é que isso em termos em termos de
o e planta essa transformação que eu
considero que é um momento grande
transformação momentos destrutivos muito
forte aonde é que vem é uma onda com
muita força e nós temos que perceber ou
ficamos parados À Espera De onde
tirávamos a condição da praia EA
sensação não é propriamente a mais
agradável ou então temos outra hipótese
que a tentar surfar essa onda e
aproveitar o máximo porque os desafios
vão ser muitos mas também vão ser as
oportunidades
e ir para ti isso esses desafios são
desafios tecnológicos são desafios
sociais políticos geopolíticos
ecológicos inclusive mas são sobretudo
desafios humanos e quando nós somos mais
desafiados
Oi e pronto esses desafios humanos Eu só
vejo uma forma de nós nos conseguimos
colocar na posição em que os conseguimos
ultrapassar
é isso na nossa história entra digamos
assim Se quisermos ter essa história um
bocadinho do ponto de vista convencional
segunda parte para reinventarmos o mundo
só temos uma forma de fazer e através de
educação e plantou deste contexto este
Desafios que nos são colocados a forma
como os temos que encarar nós temos os
temas educativos são muito lentos em
termos a capacidade de respostas os
temas educativos que vamos fazer uma
metáfora só um bocadinho como é que eles
porta-contentores enormes aqueles
Petroleiros quando se querem movimentar
é muito difícil aliás nós vamos ligar
pouco tempo no Canal dos o mesmo por lá
e ficou ali um porta-contentores
encalhado e o mundo praticamente para o
e o nosso precisamos deste momento as
doenças rápidas capacidade de ver de
analisar perspectivar e rapidamente
conseguir entrar
é porque estas transformações são muito
importantes mas ao mesmo tempo foi muito
rápidas ou seja nunca assistimos forma
tão rápida alterações nas formas com nós
pressionamos um conjunto de princípios
que temos definidos
o aparelho por exemplo a nossa geração
perguntou fazer uma média de idade está
aqui é hipoteticamente a última geração
para quem a palavra offline vai ter
algum significado
o Gerson que vem ou se lhe não faz
sentido Não está constantemente
conectados como nós já estamos
conectados eu vou contar hiperconectados
montar nos Mundos dos Mundos o digital
eo analógico Possivelmente aqui que nós
falamos hoje em dia os jovens passam
muito nos telefones a seguir
Possivelmente não está constantemente em
mundos virtuais através de óculos de
realidade aumentada e coisas do gênero e
a forma de encontrar respostas no que
diz respeito aquilo que a educação e um
bom combate a nossa pequena história não
temos tempo para isso para mim é uma
forma de ver uma forma de resposta é
inverter completamente a forma como
pensamos como olhamos como discutimos e
comente implementamos educação é com
cara as coisas de perna para o ar
é uma forma em por exemplo olhamos para
o currículo currículo da sua base tem
sobretudo que estados informação depois
percepção conhecimento e forma top no
topo da pirâmide é que nós temos o o
expertise a transferência desses mesmos
conhecimentos o campo de fazer é virar
completamente ao contrário e um temos
por o foco por todos estes temas pelo
menos para já eles são extremamente
capazes No que diz respeito ao
processamento de dados de informação
inclusiva de conhecimento e que temos um
ultrapassado porque os campos que eles
estão a atingir não é só aqueles Campos
que nós considerávamos aqueles
facilmente automatizadas para reparem
temos sistemas que criam obras de arte
que cria um música que tem um coisas que
Nós pensamos nessa nossa exclusividade
em termos a inteligência
Bom dia em termos de educação a mensagem
que nós temos dar aos nossos alunos é
que se reinventem se constantemente não
acha uma cor Há muitas cores e temos ter
essa percepção e essa identificação e
essa capacidade de transmitir esta
mensagem por mais que nunca isso é
extremamente importante e se eles não
estiverem a capacidade terrível estar
constantemente os desafios vão ser mais
difíceis de superar e as oportunidades
vão ser mais difíceis de conseguir
agarrar essas oportunidades sente esta
mensagem que nós temos que transmitir um
outro exemplo em termos da nossa geração
e quando falo da nossa fala da minha
correto peço imensa desculpa em termos
da da vossa mas tem a ver com o facto de
Possivelmente uma das outras coisas que
nós somos muito uma geração de charneira
em termos de mudança olhamos
historicamente em termos do
desenvolvimento é que saiu do emprego
pra vida
e as próximas gerações e sutilmente não
fará sentido nenhum se é para o bem
sempre o mal que é necessário para
conseguir postar isso é uma discussão
que temos que fazer mas principalmente
daqui a 20 ou 30 anos os bons assim
interrogado mas como é que aquela Malta
conseguir viver tensão um emprego a
fazer sempre a mesma coisa durante a
vida toda desafios é que eles tinham
correto e essa forma de interrogar e
essa forma de pensar estamos torna
extremamente importante nos nossos
alunos em que uma das competências que
eu gostaria de ouvir mais falar e
pessoalmente não sou tanto falar que é
questão da curiosidade sendo curiosos
ter a constante vontade de aprender isso
vamos constantemente a reinventar-se
isso é importante que os temas
educativos tivessem essa capacidade de
integrar da capacidade de lançar esses
desafios da forma que eles pensassem eu
tenho que aprender constantemente eu
tenho que estar adaptar constantemente e
isso a curiosidade é sem dúvida alguma
é um fator importantíssimo fator crucial
o qual até o final da história não faço
a mínima ideia
a cada um de vocês tem que pensar nesse
final uma coisa eu sei nós neste momento
ainda estamos no cômico nós neste
momento ia podemos decidir isso como a
controlar o melhor joystick isso no
final da história não foi propriamente o
final da história que nós estamos
habituados
e o final feliz a culpa vai ser
sobretudo no ainda correto nós vamos
depois colocar eles e isso é importante
nós temos essa essa essa percepção e
perceber que não é só olhando para o
passado está olhou para presente com os
olhos embaixo Mas é sobretudo olhar para
o futuro é perceber tentar perspectivar
tentar ter enquadramento tentar ter por
sessões para que somos todos
conjuntamente todas estas transformações
todas estas opções todos esses Desafios
que nos são assados nós temos que
capacidade de luz enfrentar e o futuro
só se consegue construir o futuro que
nós queremos se o pensarmos
Olá neste caso se o criarmos isso é
clareamento o mais importante
é muito obrigado a